REFUSAL TOVETHONGE
YOU ULD HAVE A DIFFEREOPINION.
DO?IS THU TO TO
D T
WAS I THINK THATU  YOUE VOTEHAT
THINK THAT -- THE VICE PRESIDENO
THAND ITRY, VERY CLEARLY THE CO
UNITED STATES.E HE'S JUS
SUPPOSED TO BE T SIMMEDIATELY HO
TRUMP'INAL Y
FASCINATING READ.
PENCE
AL PENCE.
YOU ASKED E NT OPLE WHOO GOO THI
HATEWEOT OF THEM
HANG MIKE PENC
>> AN WHAT DID DONALD TRUM
ED FOR VICURN TH NUT IN  HE THOE
DONE. SAID PENCE SHOULD N STT
FOLLOWIN FOUR YEARS WAA STATUE,E
FIND D TOMAGINE THE PRESIDENTE
ELD
VI PT HE WANTED
HIHIABSOLUTELY HIM.
>> YEAH.
>> HE ABSOLUTE
LT
PR CLIP
FROM YOUR INTERVIEW  THE
FORMHE
ABOUT WATCH.
>> WHO WILL YOUR VICE PRESIDENT
AN LOVES A DECISION T. WL SAY T
YOU SAW TH97%.
>> YOU'RE NOT LOCKED IN YOU
WOULRUENCE AGAIN?
PRIMARY.NOT LOCKED INTNG. N AI
HE WANTS TRUN FOR PRESIDENT
TOO.>> EVERYBODY- FREE
COUNTRY, RIGHT.COUNTRY.
SO WERE  REPUBLICANS, AP
THOMSON JEFFERSON, HAD HE  K WHS
WHAT THOMAS JEFFERSON DID,
WE'RE TAKINGOTES HE D TH BUT
HAVE BEEN
TO THEISTU NOW
TH BADSH
LETTERS FROMHE
STATES WE'RE TAL ABO.
HAD HEONE HINK IT
WON A GREAIN
FOR OUR COUNTRY.LD HAVE BE A
E WHAT BIG-SCALE ARE.T THE IDEA
SPREADING THESE LIES AND
BELIEVING THESES AND PROP SES M
KIND OIS, I MEAN, IT'S EOR
EN THIS S  ANE TH AEA
COMING O IER S BY A MAKE ITIER
VOTEHIG
REANS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS WAS ACTUALLY A VICTORIOUS R
BECAUSE -- BECAUSENSRN IN A
AL THEDONALD TRUMP.
OME  THE
TELL TRUMP T BILL
MR. PRESIDENT, ALLATYOU'REINGGED
DU VOTES
WE'VE LOOKEDO 'R
BSCTO HIM, H DTHK N THIS STATETB
HOW CAN THAT BE?EALLAMAZED
TOT HOW MUCH DONALD
TRUMP'S INNERRATIVE HA
Y CONSPIRACY THEOR AND
I HEARD PEOPLEG IN HIS
HED TOANNE CE LOSTD , I'M SOON
BUT AS TIMHINAE IS MORE Y LACKI
FACT BUT HE'SP
AROUND TREHT WHO ARE NG CONTRADO
SP AND  TAT'S NOT REALITY.
>> THAT'S R INTERVIE
TRUMP LAURA
OF THINGS PTED,OF-AO
RESIDENT TO
PUT THINGS IN HIS EA E SAID SOMA
MONT INTERVIEW, AS I HE WAS QUI
TO CHS WH
R DINN OTI MENED WE OLLOW-UPUEIA
THIS
REMARKED, YOU SPENT A
LOT OF TE WITHMRTRUMP,
USE E
BAI ED, YOU IT'
ENJOYED  YOU KNO IT'S
IT.A EA
BEENT MAYBE ATING.T LIKE THE'S
CH INTO